[Music]
everybody is there promoting their big
movie everybody and that includes in
John Cena and I got the first interview
with John since he and his former
fiancee Nikki Bella and now it's over
all your fans want to know how you're
doing how you're feeling what sucks no
there's no other way to say that that's
it's a I love Nicole with all my heart
and that's it would you marry me
one year after John proposed on live TV
Nikki announced they were over just ten
days later the WWE star / actor was back
to work promoting his upcoming
Transformers spin-off bumblebee it truly
is a major thing I'm very happy to be
being able to be part of this the film
tells the origin story of the famed
yellow autobot and also stars Hailee
Steinfeld were you a fan of hers before
you do you like her music
we both share parallels we both come
from live entertainment and we do film
as well
she's a very driven human being the 21
year old singer actress is set to kick
off a world tour starting in the UK and
she's really psyched about another big
event across the pond the royal weddings
coming up are you guys excited or uiview
out she's got the paper huh oh yeah it's
a moment in history first of all but
it's just it's exciting to see it all
come together I mean I I don't know it's
gonna be Justin it's a big deal right
Royal Wedding yeah I'll figure it out
here on Twitter